for much of the year the town of st.
Helen in northern Greece is a tranquil
place of just 700 people like kiri Arcos
Pat's us most feel blessed to live here
[Music]
kiri Arcos is the chief icon bear in a
firewalking festival called the Aniston
Aria the ritual revolves around a set of
ancient icons that worshippers believe
have special powers to purify heal and
protect one story claims that a thousand
years ago worshipers rescued the icons
from a burning church escaping
miraculously unscathed
[Music]
ever since their descendants have
carried the icons into the fire to prove
their faith and to seek blessings from
Saint Constantine but others view the
ritual s sacrilege
the less you lip service the people who
oppose the tradition dislike the fact
that we take the icons along in the fire
that's why they claimed the tradition is
pagan at the bezel nude study dunya Shia
- the Metropolitan Bishop of Lang
goddess the in Austin Aria ritual is
pagan a hangover from ancient times when
people worshipped the Sun in the moon he
believes Aniston Aryans are be trained
Saint Constantine
guess after Tuesday's dr-dos Hasbrouck
in this lifetime burgers you give them a
slepping I think Constantine is a sinker
and they think an act that weight is an
insult today we can verify that edge you
know they're not trying to trading after
Navy villages as sunset approaches for
shippers build a bonfire inside the
shrine the final ceremony begins as
always with ancient folk songs played on
the Lear
[Music]
Cariocas takes on the sacred icon the
saint and their faith in him is the only
protection the Austin area will take
into the fire he traverses the hot coals
first north to south then a second pass
east-west his steps form a cross and he
appears to feel no pain one by one the
followers of the Saint take the plunge
the ceremony continues until the embers
are almost stamped out kyriakos is
elated I feel so joyful the Saints for
with us
science has offered possible
explanations for firewalking one is that
perspiration forms a buffer of vapor
between skin and coal but back at the
shrine the faithful need no further
explanation kiri Arcos believes he has
secured the blessings of Saint
Constantine for another year